9-1-1 where is your emergency
yes i just had an officer come to 117
gloria trail about my brother but he's
up there at my mama house and he don't
pull a knife and jumping on my my mama
in there and she said 2407. hey with
brockton road 24 right up the road
okay
all right hold on a second
and you look at my daughter
and i'm about to ride my car
all right you say he has a knife on your
mother
yes he he don't pull a knife on my
brother my stepdad and my um
okay
and he's punching
they was just at my location i was
telling the officer that um my mom and
dad kept calling me saying that he was
trying
2407 hey
yeah um that he was about to jump on
them and the people was like that they
had to call it in and i was like how can
they call it in when he already starting
it up they whip them and so the officer
left from here and said that they were
going on going back to their office or
whatever
and cleared it out from at this location
okay
so they just called me on video on call
and he got the knife and stuff at him
and punching my mama and they're all in
their face
all right so they're all ready for you
they're already familiar with them and
everything right we got them on the
phone even they coming
okay what's your name ma'am we we have
them coming because the people kept
telling us that if y'all don't call the
police that they had to leave from
grandma everest
okay
on on the phone yeah okay did he walk
over there did he drive over there
he he on foot man he on foot okay all
right we got them coming ma'am they're
in route now okay all right all right
[Music]
that motherfucker that hit me in my head
you
hey come here drop the weapon drop the
weapon drop the weapon now get on the
ground
get on the fucking ground now
get on the ground drop the weapon
drop the weapon hold up hold up drop the
weapon
drop the weapon
drop it
drop the knife drop the knife now
drop the knife subject's got a knife we
got him at gunpoint
irving
drop it
drop it tonight
drop
drop the knife taste the taste of texas
shot's fired shot's fired
be a boss knife on plane
move out the way
drop
oh